if you're in the humanities the world
is running under your feet your life is
um created by the science to technology by the
stem science technology engineering and either
math or medicine and then on the scientist's side
you know they could be they could feel oh my gosh
you know the peoples think that we're nerds
or that we're dry people or that we only see
things as numbers as if it isn't beautiful
when you've got an equation that works I
mean they people don't understand this and so
it's a lack of understanding on each side but
since I've been a science fiction writer my
whole life I've been trying to say science
is actually quite modest in that it doesn't
want to tell people what to do or what things
mean so science scientists doing their science
well will be quite they won't claim more for
science than it is attempting right it's just
to explain things and once you if you clarify
that to people in the humanities and they get
over this notion that oh scientists have taken
over the world and they and when actually they
haven't they just have provided an amazingly
powerful tools right any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from Magic [Music]
welcome everybody to what promises to be an out
of this world adventure with a HomeTown hero a
favorite son of UCSD and California in general but
really of of Earth and Mars Fame and that's Kim
Stanley Robinson Stan as we know him here renowned
science fiction author but also non-fiction author
and today we're talking about two of his books
that I've had an incredible impact on me and uh
just my thought process including my hero Galileo
Galilei who uh was really the last time we were
together for an official event of any kind was
in 2012 I think it was uh maybe it was 2014.
and I was commemorating the 400th anniversary of
Galileo or the 400th anniversary of the telescope
I believe it was we'll put some b-roll and
we'll show that here yeah so you and I and
Mario bajajoli who's a professor now he's at uh
UCLA he was at Davis at the time where you spend
a lot of time and we did at a birthday party
for Galileo uh and in the back of my mind it
was in February which Galileo's birthday is
the day after Valentine's Day February 15th
and I knew that a month later we'd be announcing
to the great Fanfare that we discovered waves of
gravity percolating through the universe courtesy
of a refracting telescope just like the one that
Galileo utilized to peer into the heavens but
I couldn't make that note so I was keeping a
deep secret while we were speaking but we did
a wonderful event together and you're back on
campus to do more events you've been so prolific
we're going to talk about Galileo's dream which
really is you know probably my favorite science
fiction book fantasy fan fiction I don't know how
you think of it but that's the way I think
about it um 20 hours of goodness that I've
listened to multiple times and we're also going
to be talking about something that's also near
and dear to my heart which is uh which is the
subject of your latest book which is uh about
the Sierra Nevada mountain range which is not far
from here and I didn't realize how much time you
spent there including time when you're spending
time here so first of all Stan welcome to UCSD
welcome back welcome home uh we love having you
here and you're so gracious with your time to to
spend some time with us we have questions from the
audience we have questions from me and and so for
but first of all I wanted to ask you what drove
you you know I mean predominantly you're known as
science fiction writer of the highest magnitude
Hugo nebula all the awards he could win right
um what tribute to write a non-fiction
book about the Sierra Nevada mountain range
well I I've wanted to for decades but I am a
science fiction novelist and I had um novels
to write contracts to fulfill so it kind of just
sat there in the back of my mind and it was also
um something to think about when I was hiking
because hiking is an all-day thing the hours pass
you got time to think it is um you it's a double
Consciousness maybe I mean it's a space that
demands your attention and gets your attention
it's a beautiful space to walk in the High Sierra
but also there's time especially on trail to
ponder you know how would you write this down
in sentences which is something that always
comes to me to me and I gotta say um before I
forget thank you so much for mentioning Galileo's
dream it's one of my favorite of my own novels
I love it because I love Galileo and that was an
opportunity and it since then I've been on a roll
um partly contractual partly life situation partly
a wonderful editor Tim Holman who platformed me
and that's now seven novels back and it it's
um I think it's a little lost in the shuffle of
my career compared to my other novels since and
the people who like Galileo or think of it as a
historical novel well it's got some pretty weird
chapters the people who think of it as a science
fiction novel there's an awful lot of detail
about Galileo's people and quantum entanglement
and his life in in Florence and Pisa and in
Rome so if you're a science fiction fan it's
too historical if you're a historical fan is too
science fictional so maybe that's one explanation
for it or just who you never know but I'm very
happy that you like that book because I like
it a lot too because he here's what he taught
me I was feeling low I was feeling thrashed I
had finished a novel a Trilogy set in Washington
DC and then had kicked my ass and I was thinking
maybe I'm done and then I started working on
Galileo I moved and started writing Outdoors
that was important but more important was Galileo
I realized that guy he went through a lot of hard
stuff physical ailments including going blind
um the pope putting him under house arrest and
almost burning him at the stake his daughter
died young when he was still alive these are
um this is that's as difficult as life gets in
terms of throwing hard things at you and all
he did was work more he just worked harder
and um they his famous book the DIA logo is
um um uh justly famous but the one he wrote
at the end of his life the best course the
discourse yeah is amazing and simply amazing and
and so you know everything that he ever thought
for 40 years put into one book and at that point
I felt a little embarrassed for myself or a little
ashamed of myself thinking you know you think
you have it hard so just start working and I
started working and I realized he had the secret
that actually my low point was basically probably
from spending too much time indoors and getting
bored with sitting at a laptop indoors when I
moved outdoors I was enjoying riding again I had
the good editor so Galileo taught me some really
important lessons and and people don't really
realize so I had the honor to because of the
University of California press owns the rights
to the definitive translation by Stillman Drake
of the dialogue I had the honor of Performing and
creating the very first audiobook ever by Galileo
which is the dialogue read by uh my friend Carlo
ravelli and another friend Italian Friend Lucio
piccharillo so we play it in actual performance so
we act it out in this audiobook which one were you
uh so I was uh I am totally you were simplistic
no no no my friend Carlo is of course alviati
yeah I am a segreto and then there's simplicio
the the Pope's character feudally but the thing
that kind of does remind me of of of Galileo
when I read your writing is there's a poetry
there are sections of Galileo's dream where you
describe there's not a spoiler I don't think you
can spoil it correct me from can you spoil a book
that's 12 years old or whatever no no talking your
very last page could be discussed so but which
I won't but their passages where you describe
Galileo visiting the moons of of Jupiter and you
describe the rich ochres the Tans the purples and
it's a page but it's it's rapturous and I listen
to the I love hearing your voice and The Narrative
of that book is a is a wonderful narrator I wish
I could have gotten him for some of my books uh
instead of me but but when you have this eye it
reminds me of Galileo there are passages in the
dialogue which are the deepest poetry he speaks
at sometimes and he's of course speaking with
some false humility because he had a healthy ego
as I want to get into as a great scientist great
writer I think you need a little bit of a Swagger
to do good to do greatness and balance that with
humility but he said in the final passage he said
I have not meant to travel roads never trodden
but merely to open a portal to Vistas such that
other Travelers much more perspicacious than me
will be able to unveil Secrets which I can only
dimly grasp but he has just this beautiful way
of writing evocative he talks about the sun with
all those planets revolving independent upon of
course that's what he was trying to prove which
he didn't successfully do in that book but he says
still finds time to ripen a bunch of grapes on
the vine it's just it's just amazing and I think
about your writing in this new book about the High
Sierras you have this this this real poetic sense
of attention to detail which I'm wondering is
that born of a scientific curiosity not unlike
Galileo's where does that come from the attention
to detail that you're known for well I wonder
certainly most of the scientists I've known
they're fascinated by what they're studying
so it's not just a job it's a form of devotional
practice in other words you're you're the the pain
of attention is a kind of a worship of reality
and Galileo was very much in that mode the the
world was kind of a miracle to him filled with
Mysteries and some of his theories were wrong
I mean the tides vexed him without gravity
without calculus he was constantly at the edge
of his own understanding and super curious so
he's paying attention and throwing theories out
there and he was a beautiful stylist his I'm
told by Mario since I don't read Italian but
that you know along with a Machiavelli and Dante
they sort of turned the Florence the Florentine
um uh dialect into classical Italian High
Italian because of their powers as writers
that just became the norm for written Italian
when there were so many dialects at the time
well it makes sense to me reading him in English
he's Vivid he cuts to the chase there was a
tradition in his time of debase after dinner
you know because it was a patronage system and
you were entertaining the duke or the medicis or
the any or the or the the the elected well yeah
in Venice so two people would go at it and have a
debate and a God you would have lost it got loud
exactly he did have a healthy ego because he
knew he was smarter than almost anybody alive
in his time and I had such pleasure throwing
him into weird situations you know like the
the years but but going into the year 3000 if
you threw that at Galileo he would be doing
his best to comprehend it and when in one of my
future characters says to him you know well you
know of course you can't know everything um
that there is to know and he's like why not
I I know everything there's you know in my
time how has the year 3000 any different and
um a thorough going pleasure to contemplate and
Mario biagioli kept telling me do not romanticize
this guy he was a real son of a [__] he was
uh he was a schemer and a grasper there was no
such thing as intellectual property rights he
had to fight and scheme and I mean he he had
uh he wasn't unscrupulous by by any means he had
Scruples and and values but but he was had to be
tough yeah Mario points out he concealed how the
telescope was perfected by him not invented it was
a form of you know property and then trademark
investment for his own safety as you point out
he had all these people depended on him right yeah
that's right and he and when he had his that first
book about the Moon published he put the actual
statistics last in a kind of a supplement so that
he couldn't be ripped off before the rest of the
book came out it was a a smart man in a difficult
time and um it it's a nice to think I mean I'm
not a scientist uh I am an English major and
a novelist so what are novels about these are
long complicated stories it might not even be
a major quality of my novelizing that I
like being in the Sierras and attending
to that world I was just reminded of this
an hour ago I walked onto black speech and
back well I spent a lot of my youth as a as an
undergraduate at UCSD down there at that beach and
um it sort of forces you to pay attention and
especially being in the water and swimming and
making sure you don't drown right you talk about
almost succumbing to the tide the currents here
yeah yep I have three near drying events in my
uh childhood and youth one at Corona del Mar one
at Newport Beach and one right down in Ohio Shores
which is a very simple asset yeah yeah most of the
time I blew it it was a stupid mistake when I was
young and overconfident and I must say the waves
break much further offshore down here than they
do in Orange County so it was a simple perceptual
error I said oh the waves aren't very big and when
I got out there they were and I got thrashed maybe
the water was cold whatever I love it and so
of course the interesting thing is can you put
this into sentences where other people can kind
of imagine it mm-hmm so I can almost grasp you
know writing non-fiction books as I've done now
twice um but the the fictional world it's it's a
mystery to me it seems like such a different skill
set it's like it runs a jiu jitsu master and one's
like a chef but I know there must be commonalities
between the processes but I wonder can you talk us
through your your what is your deal you're in
it you have a contract you're working on a new
book it's a fictional book yeah does your daily
routine does it differ from nonfiction to fiction
a and what is it in any case what is your daily
what is your operating routine there are a lot
of young men who listen to Young Women too that
listen to about what is your routine to achieve
you know to get into a flow what do you do well
it's been I've only written one non-fiction book
right except for my um PhD thesis which wasn't
a real well it was but in any case it's always
been fiction and my routine is very simple I
treat it like work I don't wait for inspiration
to strike you can't do that with novels so I
get up at breakfast the family would go off
to school into work I would be there I would
sit down I would write from after breakfast to
um lunch and then maybe write again in the
afternoon first draft maybe not um if I was
revising I would write it as long as I was awake
and many a day I would actually after breakfast
go out to the Garden this is very Galileo he did
this too yeah and I would pull weeds and garden
for about an hour get my hands dirty think things
over like what am I gonna write today and kind of
and Ponder what the scene needed in some very
general sense because it never comes sharp until
you're writing the sentences themselves and then
the scene actually happens by some strange moment
where I don't want to be mystical about it but
I'm not fully there myself making decisions it's
more like ah yes that it must have been this way
because that's the only that's a combination of
the most interesting and the most believable at
the same time so let's write that down and see
what it looks like so first draft and then I go
off and I usually would go for a run or go swim
a workout or go play Frisbee golf do something
athletic because sitting on my butt is not really
my thing despite my job and then revision as I
would say I I can revise as long as I'm awake
and also but for the afternoons research doing
science fiction especially as an English major I'd
write a scene and then I'd say to myself if this
scene was going to be really good good I would
have to know more I'd have to know X Y and Z but
it was specific to the scene so my research was
reiterative and supportive and was expressed in
between the first draft and the subsequent drafts
so write a scene try it out realize what you would
need to know to make it better find that stuff out
try it again and fit in the new information and
a lot of times the research that I did subsequent
to the first draft would change the story
itself considerably because in the research I
would learn more that that actually told me you
can't even do that or that's wrong let's it's
better to do it right because it would be more
interesting so it's been a reiterative process and
um well I was taking care of my kids because now
they're grown up now but when they were young and
I was Mr Mom I would work Monday through Friday
and Saturdays and Sundays I would fool around with
the family and do chores once they grew up enough
I just started working seven days a week and I got
into streaks like I one time I worked 220 days in
a row and it's a streak sort of like Cal Ripken
where occasionally I would be going to bed and
realize I hadn't ridden that day and I'd write
one paragraph to keep the streak live right but
um it's good for writers to keep a streak wherever
every day you don't get to decide you're going to
write that date you don't know what you're going
to write but you're going to write something and
that way you have seven fifths more work done in
every week than if you take your weekends off yeah
I think Stephen pressfield in the war of art says
something like I only write when I'm inspired but
fortunately inspiration strikes every morning at
9am well sometimes it doesn't meaning that he has
to put his butt in a chair yeah exactly clog it a
little and certainly until your butt's in a chair
you're not going to be inspired i i in the coveted
period And since Ministry for the future is done
and and and also since the High Sierra was done I
have been doing these little poems like Chinese
landscape poems or um Chinese widows Buddhist
dailies they're very small poems they're more like
diary entries mained into a poem there I actually
wait for inspiration something happens and I think
oh that would make a good little poem hold on to
that thought so it's completely different than
the physics I can't resistance I did teach that
class the first ever combination class taught in
Partnership between literature English literature
and physics with our mutual friend Ray armentrout
and winner of the Pulitzer Prize good old man uh
so she is hopefully listening and Ray I love you I
miss you but we used to debate and I always put up
on the first day of class I put up this following
quote by Dirac which I'll try to resuscitate the
famous physicist Nobel Laureate came up with the
concept of anti-matter and his construction of
the relativistic theory of quantum mechanics
leading to What's called the positron and he
said uh he was talking about and he was rumored
to be a very parsimonious with his language
in fact his brother-in-law said something Paul
never uses two words when none will do so uh he
said the following he said in physics we tried to
express the richness of the physical Universe in
the fewest possible terms with the small you know
most economical amount of language but in poetry
it's the opposite and Feynman of course had these
ridicules of of the poet's process he said why is
it that you know if I speak about Jupiter as being
made of methane and and hydrocarbons and so forth
that I'm somehow less well regarded than you know
Walt Whitman waxing rhapsodically about the loss
of the night's guide to numbers why is there this
you know kind of uh hostility between the physical
sciences perhaps or the the hard sciences and
and maybe the the humanities you've perceived
that well anything like that I know what he's
talking about and yes it exists as a thing and
somewhat in their minds on both sides yeah you
know it's the CP snow two cultures Division and
I gotta say Ray armentrout is an example of a true
poet in that she has a gift and this is a hard
thing to describe and I think it has to do with
a sense of Rhythm because um as a prose writer
I try to be as precise as a poet as expressive
as a poet but thoughts in Rhythm syllables that
um between the weak syllables and the strong
syllables and also the end stops of switching
to the next line at a unexpected moment that
nevertheless um um makes Bold or prominent one
thought or another or just gives you a little
internal surprise but whatever a poet is doing
she has a gift for it yeah and I don't have that
gift but I I can I can unders I can know it when
I see it as a reader right uh and as for the
two cultures split what are you gonna do I'm an
English major from UCSD and Patrick ledden used
to start his non-euclidean geometry uh classes
which I took from him and loved him with um quotes
from James Joyce he ran the Joyce Workshop here
for a while the seminar on Joyce and he when he
did chalkboards you know the non-leuclidean the
sphere with the um the hyperbolics and the line
yeah the lines at infinity and where and so he
would draw these perfect circles on the chalkboard
he was making works of art and quoting Joyce and
teaching us non-euclidean geometry which is
pretty strange stuff um and interesting in
many ways and he made it quite clear in ways
that I now look back on with some surprise
the split isn't necessary it and I wonder if
it's a little bit of insecurity on both sides
um in that if you're in the humanities the world
is running under your feet your life is um created
by the science technology by the stem science
technology engineering and either math or medicine
um and then on the scientist side you know
they could be they could feel oh my gosh
you know the peoples think that we're nerds
or that we're dry people or that we only see
things as numbers as if it isn't beautiful
when you've got an equation that works I
mean they people don't understand this and so
it's a lack of understanding on each side but
since I've been a science fiction writer my
whole life I've been trying to say they are
um shared Enterprises or they're both equally
valuable even though they are quite different
I've been trying to explain to the humanities
Moon science is actually quite modest in that
it doesn't want to tell people what to do or
what things mean it's how things work how we
might manipulate them explanations of processes
but not philosophy in the sense of meaning and not
uh ethics and not politics right so science
scientists doing their science well will be
quite they won't claim more for science than it is
attempting to do right which is to explain things
and once you if you clarify that to people in the
humanities and they get over this notion that oh
scientists have taken over the world and they and
when actually they haven't they just have provided
an amazingly powerful tools right so you know
you can go on forever on this uh Science and Arts
split but when you're a science fiction writer
and it's like oh come on you know let's let's
um get over that and talk more about what we can
do together to illuminate things and go forward
yeah it's like uh the scientist Robert Wilson I
think was one of the uh original NSF directors or
something in government in the 50s and 60s and
some congressmen asked oh what Mr Wilson what
will this new fangled particle accelerator do
you know for the defense of the country and and
he said well it'll make it worth defending but
I always invert that and say well it's really
you know the humanities that need protection
and but there also should be the highest form
of expression as you describe Professor Aladdin
we have lectures named after uh to this day yeah
um you know I think of what is the purpose of
a scholar you know what what what good do we do
and it's it's like there's a tremendous amount of
high bar that is in my mind what it means to be
a scholar but to have this diversity of curiosity
means you shouldn't just do physics and you should
that's why the course was called by the way I
didn't tell you this like the course is called
poetry for physicists oh yeah instead of a physics
for poets right so I had always wanted to do that
and one day I got an email you know I was you get
these emails I'm sure you know our Stan I'd love
to take you out the coffee or you know pick your
brain like I could get my own coffee thanks very
much and she's writing to me I'd love to take you
out to coffee and I'm in Camp oh by the way I won
the Pulitzer Prize last year but the undelete
you know like oh let me take this just not a
normal person who asks you out for a cup of coffee
and she had this incredibly discursive curiosity
about cosmology and entanglement she wrote a
poem which won one of the best poems American
poems of 2012 and it's inspired by me and you
can hear it on uh on Audible and elsewhere just
a quick pause to ask you for a small favor while
my thumb is occupied with old Albert on it yours
is presumably freed up to leave a thumbs up on
this video really helps me a lot with a good
old-fashioned YouTube algorithm thanks a lot now
back to the video but when we think about a novel
the thing that's always surprised me non-fiction
you kind of know the story I mean yes you come in
and maybe arrays you don't exactly know perhaps
what happened before the Big Bang in my case or
something like that but I I know the story I'm
trying to tell uh but with a novel especially like
it's Trilogy or multi-series multi-part series do
you have to know like someone who's obviously I'm
deeply closeted and I want to write a novel
someday oh tell me Stan like what do I need
what's the prerequisite how do you know when you
have enough like what what do you what do you need
to go on to start obviously you can start at any
time what do you what's your theoretical minimum
and the idea itself um including the resolution
like that yeah well very often yes the resolution
or where I'm headed well the idea itself um
let's see if we can terraform Mars in 200
years that has its resolution at the end you say
yes you don't say no no it's likely or now but
um uh what if you're like we're not gonna make
it to the stars that this is a false dream
that Humanity's going to the stars because of
biological constraints and in physics biological
so then oh how would you how would you show that
in a novel well let's do the most likely thing
a multi-generational Starship and then we'll
show the problems that are unsolvable given
the distances involved and then we'll put them
in a perilous State and actually I didn't quite
know my answer to that one which is my normal
Aurora Ministry for the future what's the best
case scenario for the next 30 years that you could
still believe in after I described it to you so
um these kind these are ideas the um some of them
are a little crazier um Galileo when he's looking
through his telescope and he sees the moons of
Jupiter what if he found himself there like by
some kind of matter transfer or a quantum
entanglement and he's standing on the moons
of Jupiter well that's a pretty crazy notion it's
not dissimilar to a voyage to Arcturus by David
Lindsey a novel from the 20s quite bizarre so I'm
not saying it's a particularly original idea but
once it came to me I kept pondering and itching
at it and I I have to say that's a strange idea
um I I could go through all of them what was
it like for the people who painted the Chauvet
caves 32 000 years ago living in the ice age in
in the middle of Europe what was that like well
now that's a tough speculation and an interesting
thing to try uh man what if sea level was 50 feet
higher and you were living in Manhattan so these
are these are simply the ideas and then I would
pursue from there have you gotten more or less
optimistic pessimistic about Humanity's future on
mars or interplanetary desires as Elon says kind
of proposed well interplanetary I'm I'm gung-ho
for the solar system I think um this NASA slogan
space sciences and Earth Science I totally believe
it and I I think a robust space program is is um
very good for us for for the health of this planet
um the biosphere Health um I love NASA and I
love the space program I love SpaceX um not so
sure about Elon himself these days just because
of his politics um which I don't like now but um
I think it's like Antarctica and so you know the
South Pole base there's gonna be one of those on
Mars and people at that point they won't care
they won't give a damn it'll be exactly like oh
my God there's people at South Pole right now how
amazing in 95 out of 100 people you say that to be
like well so what no it's not interesting whereas
we know it's interesting and here's a this comes
from Oliver Morton who's the environmental
editor at um The Economist and a good writer
non-fiction books he says humans are interested
in the place that we can't quite get to yet
but we hope that we could maybe through
technological achievements or through courage or
through trying repeatedly and doing stupid things
so okay for a long time is the North Pole then we
got there and indeed Amazon was on his way to the
North Pole when he heard the news that someone got
there and he just told his crew sorry we're going
south flip a yui we took what a crazy thing that
is in terms of logistics and everything else but
that's what he did and he won so then the south
pole then Everest and then after that people are
kind of at loose ends and going to the moon was as
shocking but it was interesting the moment we got
to the Moon it wasn't interesting anymore and so
Oliver speculates and I bet he's right that when
we get to Mars it'll be a nine days wonder and
everybody will freak out the astronauts will come
back home it is not it should not be a dead-end
destiny you think it's Elon won't die on Mars as
he's reputed to want I mean as Martin Reed says
he'll die in Impact potentially yeah not on impact
but he might but um it would be like saying I'm
going to and check into a Motel 6 for the rest of
my life and maybe even a Motel 6 Underground for
the rest of my life how cool is that and it's just
not cool you know I mean even the people who love
the South Pole station or McMurdo yeah they do not
say I'm never coming back I love this so much the
record is about 12 years uh but with a three-month
break in New Zealand exactly traveling about the
south island oh yeah those those antarcticans
they Count Their time down there by months oh
yeah how long you been in an hour 54 months
and you're thinking that's a little weird to
count it that way but they're taking advantage
of the the coming back and they're proud of how
much time they spent in Antarctica but they
always come back to the world as they call it
yeah from the ice to the world and you've been
there and we were talking about the this picture
where did I put that up there uh maybe it's in the
frame maybe it's not yeah it is the dry Valley so
you've been to Antarctica I've spent only time
really at the South Pole and at McMurdo Station
but I greatly prefer McMurdo because there's more
people there's soft serve ice cream on demand and
you can tell I like that uh but uh how realistic
is it past um I can't call him a graduate of UCSD
but past attendee of UCSD Andy Weir uh has
been a guest in the podcast uh very wonderful
um obviously it's a deep connection to the planet
Mars as do you uh he never graduated but uh he's
still welcome to send his uh donations to UCSC
we will take them Andy as I told you last time
um it was interesting he's very vulnerable about
his time and and uh he he answered some of the
questions about kind of existential meaning that
I'll get to at the very end of this conversation
a little bit with you um if you're continue to
be as gracious as I know you are to answer them
but he talked about really the Moon even is it's
not a dead end but in his uh his novel Artemis
after which NASA's new space program is named no I
don't think it's named after but uh but he claims
the real only economic reason to go to uh to go to
the Moon is for tourist purposes are you you know
in the same camp when it comes to the Moon and
what about with Mars exploration I am in the same
camp and I met Andy a couple of times at science
fiction events and enjoyed those meetings a lot
um the moon I wrote a moon novel called red moon
it was the one right before Ministry for the
future and I would say that it's um the Moon is
too small to be interesting and China is too big
to be comprehensible and putting the two together
I had a novel about Chinese taking over the South
Pole of the Moon which I think Could Happen um but
nevertheless it was hard to find a heroic story or
any economic reason to be there but tourism and
my addition to tourism on the moon is I think
original to me and it comes out of Galileo he
noticed that the moon was um shifting a little bit
uh like libation or Library vibration and he said
it was like a man shaving turning his head back
and forth to see the sides for shaving and so if
you were and even the polls would work with this
and the polls will have water but along the the
two limbs that we see if you were put into a hotel
there then the Earth would rise and go down on a
like two-week basis it would come over the horizon
it would be up in the low in the sky and then
I'm gonna go back down again it's almost the only
thing you'd see because everywhere else on the
moon you're going to be seeing the Stars fixed in
position right and people haven't really thought
too much even the Earth would be fixed in position
and going through its daily cycle of shade and
dark which would be interesting yeah but to have
it come up and down also so yes the Moon a dead
end and and the so-called economic reasons are
simply I'm going to say ridiculous the helium-3
the the it's quantities in astronomy and well
astronomy cool oh no it's it's practical but it's
not an economic driver I mean look at American
astronomers it's an expense right if you go to
the other side or whatever you want to do it's
like the South Pole itself exactly so if people
say we're going up there in order to make money
you gotta just laugh at them and I think tourists
um there's probably shouldn't be people Rich
enough to be able to afford to go to the Moon as
a tourist but on the other hand if we get really
um um these SpaceX reusable rockets and if it
becomes um not grotesquely expensive like the
people have been going up into low earth orbit
for 20 million dollars I mean that's probably a
sign they've got too much money and should be
taxed out of it um so tourism that's not good
either now Mars is different because it's a planet
and once we set up a scientific base there and
astronauts begin to go there spend a season come
back in The Following Season they'll have taken on
a heavy dose of radiation as you know and they'll
have had the time of their lives and they'll come
back and they'll but also same at the Moon we
don't know what that low gravity is going to do
I mean we have suspicions it's not good for you
right the microgravity is really bad for you maybe
37 would be okay maybe 16 maybe we don't know no
um it'll be experiments that astronauts will be
willing to take because it's be so cool it's
a thrill yeah the thrill of it yeah it might
be one of our uh also illustrious alumni Jessica
Maier who is a graduate of Scripps institutional
geography I'm kind of hoping that she'll go
be the first woman on the moon because uh I
got to interview her twice once while she
was in the ISS floating above my head wow
um let's shift gears to things that Galileo noted
about the the similarity between the Earth and the
moon those are mountains uh the Sierra it's a love
story and you tell it and there are characters in
it I don't want to spoil some of the some of this
but it is dedicated to a friend talk about Terry
talk about your your friend who's uh yeah not with
us what a team did you did you know you knew him
from your UCSD days or I knew him from sixth
grade in up in Orange County we were friends
together close friends from seventh grade on in
sixth grade he was in a different class and was
just a formidable opponent on the sports Fields
because they played class against class and then
in seventh grade we became good buddies and
we were ever since uh up to a certain point
um and I want to say parenthetically that Galilei
was so cool in that being the geometrician that
he was that when he saw there were mountains on
the moon he made a pretty damn good calculation
of how tall they were and it had the moon sized
also right um impressive as hell that meant but
my friend Terry was also impressive he was a
chemistry major here at UC San Diego we roomed
together our senior year up in Del Mar and he went
up to the Sears with another UCSD friend Daryl
bonan and came back down and said to me and Joel's
who I just talked to yesterday before yesterday on
his birthday he's out in Hawaii a Joe and Terry
and I went up to the Sears together under Terry's
uh um encouragement he said look we got to go up
there it's great let's go to Desolation it's such
a fantastic name it must be the best place up
there and uh for years for decades this was a
pattern go to the Sears with Terry learn he was
a creative guy he wanted to make gear lighter
he didn't trust the commercial companies he
thought their products were mostly crap and
he was often right he was way ahead of the curve
on ultralight backpacking and these through hikers
that go from Mexico to Canada in a single season
he was one of those and it was all his own gear
and the industries the cottage industries
that have come up to serve that community
where they're not just concerned with ounces
but with grams I mean they want a backpack
that weighs five pounds plus some food yeah
one extra bristle on a toothbrush yeah yeah
and he was a he was like that just out of
a personal drive and he he liked to hike
I'm gonna say he liked to hike 15 and 20 miles a
day that's what made him feel good in the series
and he I'm talking about on trail and I'm the one
that kept insisting let's get off Trail let's go
see places where nobody else goes because he would
have been content to Trump trails and indeed when
this through hiking came into being he was fond of
it he did it twice but then he came down with ALS
and uh but Lou Gehrig's disease like with Stephen
Hawking said but many he's like many people who
catch that disease they're dead within a year I
don't know if there are different um varieties of
it I don't know why once he won some people can
persist first decades decades and other people
they they measure your hand strength and they can
tell you how many months you have left and when
they found diagnosed him he had about six months
left this was back in I don't know 2018 or 2019.
so and and I um you know before that what
I've been reading about ALS is that it can
have mood and cognitive effects before
the physical physical effects show up
whether that's true or not somehow he got um
distrustful of uh almost everybody in his life
so this was a sad thing to see and it impacted
the last decade of his life pretty Emily and it
wasn't a happy time for him but it's important
to remember that for decades before that he was
a kind of I thought of him as a kind of a thorough
figure I'm out for sure a mountain Guru he wanted
to go up there he was having fun up there and
one time I saw a walrus uh at a zoo where you
know them on land and they're just clumping
around right and then if you see them under
water like penguins they're graceful they are
uncontrolled Michael Phelps yeah yeah exactly
well Terry in the Sierras was in his element
and down in in Civilization he was not in his
element he wasn't comfortable it's just the way
it was with him I see the eye Sierra as sort of a
different incarnation of Abby's desert Solitaire
in some ways and there's a phrase that's never
left me from that book which I want to get your
reaction to which is that you know you can't live
on the ocean um you can't live on the mountains
you fall off or something like that you can live
in the desert and you can kind of persist there
and it's a stable environment how do you react to
that do you agree with Abby or not no it's such
a Desert Rat um um there's a beautiful book by
what is his name it's called the desert by a guy
who had a fever around 1902 and cured it doctors
told him to go out and live in the desert no I'm
sure it's Beaver it's like Heisenberg's hay fever
yeah his name will come to me but there's only a
few books called the desert and Abby was like that
these Desert Rats they they love it out there
and they you know maybe they're a bit nocturnal
maybe they're a bit don't like it to be cold
although you can be cold in the desert as you know
but it isn't um sustainable you would have to
be one of an indigenous person that really knew
that landscape and then if you're an indigenous
person and you knew that landscape you wouldn't
you'd go to the Owens Valley you'd go into the
rivers you'd be on on the Cottonwood rivers in
the desert you wouldn't be out there where it was
completely desolated and without water because you
need to live and have both food and drink that's
right now the High Sierra it's somewhat similar
and somewhat not um there are summer encampments
up there that the native The Californians went
up to every summer and to boost pass is one
that I write about because I saw it myself
and the reason we know that that was a summer
encampment for hundreds of years is there are
obsidian flakes everywhere in that Meadow I mean
thousands of obsidian Flakes and so you can't get
there other than these are not never endemic they
were brought by humans they were chipped off of
blocks and the the chips came from obsidian Dome
so they only carried them I don't know maybe 20
miles 30 miles and well obsidian Dome is up near
mama so maybe 40 miles but in any case they're
there up in taboo's pass and all over the Sierra
yeah obsidian flakes so a summer encampa but in
the winter you know gonna be up there you go down
to the valleys below right and so it is livable
and unless you get on the vertical faces like
climbers do it's not particularly dangerous but
um I must say I've often thought about this food
up there they were probably a killing deer with
snares or with arrows and they were probably
pulling Meadow onions and also they had such a
good supply of acorns and pine nuts and and carry
up a backpack full of uh pine nuts ready to eat
or acorns that had already been leached grounded
yeah exactly so um it was pretty robust but not
the actual Local Food Supplies once you get up
a baba out say 8 000 feet is relatively minimum
um so a main character in the book is John Muir
and I'm proud to say I am a member of Muir College
we have this college system here at UCSD as you
know and other may not know but John Muir is one
of them now he has complicated Legacy you and I
talked about this in Washington DC when we were
there I should also mention that you're gracious
enough to participate in events for the RFC Clark
Center for human imagination which I'm honored to
be the associate director of I'm with Eric veery
um Patrick Coleman Stuart Volcan and others uh
but you have um you and I just chat in the car
uh on your way uh our both Mutual Way to the
Amtrak station after Michio Kaku and others
won the uh and you spoke as well at the Clark
Foundation awards that was fun couple years ago
um and that was a great time but you and I
talked about Muir and sort of some of the
complicated aspects of his of his life and
and his career I love the portrayal I love
the quotes that you use you do talk about it in
the book famous one of course I found by going
out I was really going in yeah um what does Mira
mean to you and what do you say to those who says
his legacy has been tarnished and compromised in
some sense yeah well I conceive of myself as a his
defense attorney because that is a this that
is a calumny he has been mischaracterized
um and this was a kind of a click bait gotcha
moment a canceled culture moment of 2020
um of the executive director of the Sierra Club
cravenly gave into it and supported it she found
it or almost he he didn't find you mentioned the
book yeah he well he certainly was well involved
but there were men mostly men in San Francisco
who came to him and said well you'll help us
start a Sierra Club and he said hell yeah um and
the leader in 2020 yeah so so this is a moment
that has passed I was extremely angry in 2020
because um the people who were accusing him of
racism they had not read him and I've read him
and I mean in full even to the point of going to
his archives at University of Pacific in Stockton
California and reading all the unpublished stuff
I needed to be sure right like um to prove a
negative is difficult as you know and this is
one of the scientists big problem so if I say
no he was not a racist well how do you prove a
[__] and one way to try is to read everything
yeah and I have to say there's a dozen sentences
of him of his that are obnoxious um that are a
little ignorant on his part and a little judgy
um he was Presbyterian his dad whipped him through
his Youth and childhood he was kind of PTSD he
didn't like seeing people sitting around during
the daytime and he didn't like people with dirty
clothing at both of those things he found shocking
and sinful not that he stayed a Christian but he
had these attitudes beaten into him um but aside
from about a dozen sentences his admiration for
Native Californians and Native Americans in
general was strong and he never had much of
anything to say about the recently freed slaves of
the South when he was a kid he hiked all the way
down to Florida and saw the shattered South and
he made relatively objective sometimes admiring
admiring comments sometimes critical comments
sometimes ignorant comments about the black people
he met in the South but once he got to California
he had very little contact with them at all so if
you hunt for these sentences the new executive
director of the Sierra Club Ben jealous whose
previous job was at the NAACP right Benjo said
once recently you know mirror sometimes he sounds
like a guy writing in the 19th century and I think
that's so well put um and there are some sentences
that are 19th century sentences that we wouldn't
say now right it fell into the 20th century
unfortunately but right it is plucked out of the
record oh what a bad man but I want to finish the
point by saying what did Mir actually do yeah
because Audubon had slaves and even uh krober
um Ursula Gwen's father um he had his name taken
off of buildings in Berkeley because he had ishi's
brain sent to the Smithsonian and because he
told the federal government that some of the
Native Californians around the San Francisco Bay
did not constitute tribes and that kept them from
getting Federal listings and so their lives were
impacted by Kroger's opinions Muir never did any
of that and the main accusation against mirror
as to doing stuff was that he encouraged the
national park system to kick Native Americans off
their land in order to make a pure Wilderness that
never happened that absolutely did not happen
he died before the National Park Service right
was established but also he never said that to
anybody not to Teddy Roosevelt not to anybody
he I mean when he said everybody should go up to
the mountains and get their Glad Tidings he was
thinking of his white middle-class audience that
were in the cities but he was certainly never said
they should get these native Californians out
of here to make a better Wilderness Area that
is simply a lie and now that I've read all of
him and seen the context he actually said once
these native Californians they live so well
in the landscape right they made them yeah
yeah he did and he said also it's clear that they
burned this valley floor in order to clear it for
to make Parkland out of it so this people who
accused him of not even knowing the ecological
fire management practices they're wrong about
that too right so to I mean I don't want to go
on too long about this but mirror a heroic figure
the world's most famous Environmental list and he
still is worth valuing because the Sierras are the
way they are because he was such a good writer too
like Galileo he could capture the Beauty and
the sacredness of the Outdoor World right he's
eminently uh eminently quotable as well yeah um
so I want to ask a couple final questions and
wrap up with my existential you used to call it
the thrilling three now I call it the final four
we'll see how many we can get to I know you've got
a huge event coming up and not too long from now
um first though I want to pitch an idea to you uh
my nascent entry into science fiction so Kim pray
there is a National Academy member Professor
atmospheric chemistry she's closely associated
with the idea of atmospheric Rivers which you
talk about in your book is Pineapple Express
is what it used to be Brandon now now it's kind of
Revisited but one of her theories and sorry Kim if
you're listening another Kim uh famous Kim acsd
Associated last night um so one of our theories
is that microbes May control the generation and
diminution of the atmospheric River phenomena
when there's a drought that they do nuclear
and they do cause this upwelling and so forth
that they enter into the atmosphere providing
nucleation sites for precipitation to fall which
then cures the drought right so here's my pitch to
you you're the uh you're the book agent right okay
um can we turn this into a science fiction novel
or the microbes are taking over the planet maybe
add in some Paul Davies a little Shadow biosphere
because they're not from Earth perhaps but they
want to maintain the Earth so that we can get
to planet borkon and then save anyway what do
you think yay or nay through the Caligula do the
thumbs up though holy moly go for it all right go
for it um I I don't start it here first yes I you
need to figure out the plot and uh here's what I
say a plot is something goes wrong that's really
the quick definition of a plot and you don't want
to read a novel that doesn't have a plot that's
I I've had my my butt whipped for trying that
um and it doesn't work so uh what I love about
this is I'm right now reading the correspondence
between James Lovelock and and Lynn margulis
and it's a funny and interesting um dialogue
between the two of them as they work out this
homeostasis or this cybernetic feedback loops
and she's the Biola and he's the cyberneticist
and all-around space cadet super scientist he's
lower Buck was really good although erratic and
strange an independent scholar and but he he they
didn't want to make it um Mother Earth they didn't
want a personification they wanted a name for a
it was it's actually somewhat hard to describe
what guy is with some kind of supra organism
that is self a not well see all that yeah it's all
personified that right yeah yeah but homeostatic
is a good way to put it into just um cybernetic
terms um but with living elements in it that want
to live and are encouraged by living so what I
love about this idea is um I just think Lovelock
and margulis would love it yeah interesting yeah
all right well it gets at least a provisional
stamp of approval all right Stan we've reached the
sort of end where we transition into questions of
existential import and all of these in some way
or another are tangentially or directly related
to quotes of the great Arthur C Clarke did you
meet Arthur by phone only okay yeah but he had
a deep influence on you and passed an upcoming
guest Peter diamandis who also sends regards and
oh yeah he's a great friend of the Clark Center as
well um so Clark would say many things so one of
my favorite that I love to drop on my faculty
colleagues at a faculty meeting is for every
expert there's an equal and opposite expert I love
to drop that on my department chair from time to
time um but I also said uh that any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable for magic
and if you are a subscriber to my mailing list
I call it the magic mailing list because we go
through different aspects of what Clark and
memories and and and and sort of imaginative
Concepts but I want to reimagine that question and
say what aspect of humanity is most magical to you
what what invention what would you put on an on
an obelisk on a monolith you know that could be
a time capsule a sentinel for last for billions of
years to give us the Swagger that we might deserve
to say we were here what would you put on such a
such a Talisman or you know future Shard of our
existence what should Humanity be most proud of
in your conception I'm most proud of oh my God I
don't know I mean anesthetics um um heart surgery
um medicine in general I think science came out of
an urge to reduce our suffering and and make
us more comfortable in the world less hungry
less hurt than how to do that trial and error um a
lot of early scientists were women the herb woman
um as in my novel Shaman so I would say medicine
right off the bat because now we're living like
I'm living um Extended lifetime lies in
my Mars novels I just hit 71 but I it's
only medicine that I got past about 65. um I
bet I've had my life saved twice by medicine
so I'm particularly sensitive to how lucky
we are to have the scientific project with
that as its high point now I would also say I'm
you talked about Paul Davies a wonderful writer
and thinker my God he's the only person that ever
has been able to explain some of the details of
quantum mechanics in a way that I followed him and
that's mostly metaphorical and writing ability not
mathematical in terms of his ability to explain
to a layperson he's fabulous and a good guy and
he writes about mysticism a lot and so this is
also appeared till hard to Chardon you got the
lithosphere the atmosphere you got the biosphere
and then the new duosphere which is the chardon's
word for the mental maybe the thoughts of Gaia
The Anthem yeah exactly and it is a human the
neurosphere is created by human thinking so even
the internet as a technological manifestation of
the neurosphere or I said once in my Mars books
that first Mars has a new sphere and then it got
an atmosphere in a biosphere because we thought
of it first and then did it then we instantiated
it yeah here it's the reverse on earth right so
that was what I would say medicine for sure okay
another quote from Sir Arthur um when an elderly
but distinguished scientist says something is
possible he is most certainly right when he says
something is impossible he is very likely wrong as
you stand what if you change your mind on what if
anything have you been wrong about what would you
like a mulligan about if anything whatsoever I'm
not calling you elderly by the way yeah no I would
um like to take all mentions of blockchain
out of Ministry for the future I think it
was impressive yeah I think blockchain is bad
coding and will be um a phenomenon of just this
decade and there will be better coding systems
later so but that's a trivial thing yeah um I I
that's a good question I don't know I I was at
UCSD 50 years ago I was an undergrad I was several
things converged in my brain at once and made me
who I am and ever since then I've been kind of
um bowling along like a bowling ball
enjoying life and seeing the world
um I I can't think of things that have
um caused me to change anything major in my
thinking since then but now this is probably
an admission of my my thinking has been too fixed
not that flexible I'm a creature of habit and so
my habits have been fixed for a long time well
that's Yogi Bear said if it ain't broke yeah
well I should never I should not have spent so
many years indoors that's an accident especially
as a Californians um you can spend um 50 to 100
percent more time than you do outdoors just by
deciding to and I didn't make that decision until
you know about 2006 or so do you mind having more
skin you know you've got well remarkably smooth uh
I've got a bunch of skin cancers chopped out of me
even still oh wow oh hell yeah all right last
question can Stan and I'll let you on your way
um and that's the uh the following statement by
Sir Arthur that the only way of determining the
limits of the possible is to venture Beyond them
into the impossible that's how we get the name
of this podcast after all yeah gonna ask you um
what advice to 21 year old Stan here at UCSD what
advice would you give to yourself to give yourself
the courage to do as you've done to go into the
impossible advice to your former self well can
I say as an English major and a word person that
this is not a good use of language that if you
say impossible you mean impossible and so and
Clark was bad at this too but Hughes came from
physics um there's not going to be faster than
light travel by human beings I just say that it's
impossible and you can come back in 500 years and
we'll test that out and I'll still be right then
but this is one thing that physics is very good at
you know although you know we do have dark matter
we it's not like we understand everything things
are quite mysterious right now but some things
I think are impossible so um and also this whole
notion say that okay Humanity like is destined for
the stars and if we don't make it to the Stars we
must have been idiots as a species we must have
failed but if you set yourself an impossible goal
and then you fail then you've just some the goal
was stupid or it could be like you know so it says
oh I'm superior to you Stan because I have a nicer
phone than you you know who's the most powerful
people on Earth they don't even have phones
someone else has a phone for them right yeah
yeah so it's a false dichotomy it is indeed and
and these the use of language we have all these
words that are um getting squished out of their
natural element and being overused and pressured
to the point where they blow up like a balloon
that you've stopped so that um you know the word
artificial intelligence what if the name what if
you just said uh extremely rapid computation or
Freedom what if you change that to God knows what
or people say oh he's very unique and you've got
to understand that unique cannot take adjectives
so you get into English major um Harrison right
about words um I would say if you put a tears
of yourself if going back you're teleported
through their quantum mechanical wormholes
gone back stands here what do you say to him
don't worry too much about making mistakes the
mistakes will lead to later developments that are
so cool that this play of title of Shakespeare's
all's well that ends well if it ends well then
the crap along the way was necessary so don't
don't fret about mistakes I often did that
those mistakes actually led me into the life I'm
in so and I think maybe you know it's got to be
a time of anxiety climate anxiety um anxiety
about jobs and careers in a world in flux and
a gig economy and everything's changing and people
who are 20 years old a day they're 50 years coming
for them is going to be wild be easy to be anxious
well you just gotta ride the wave and and you know
all's well it ends well very well from one great
Wordsmith to another it's Dan thank you so much
for being so gracious with your time your effort
your support of the Clark Center and everything
you do for UCSD and San Diego and the World At
Large for the Sierras which I know you love thank
you for writing this love letter to them and uh
and your many Works along the way thank you so
much well thank you Brian it's a real pleasure you
know me I love UCSD I love mirror College I love
the Clark Center I loved Clark and so we are right
on the same Vibe with all this stuff fantastic
yeah thank you all any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from Magic
[Music]